of long covert can be ambiguous and
leave sufferers overwhelmed with
questions but now patients can get clear
answers he connected with a viral
pathologist who helped develop a new
blood test to diagnose long covid he's
also the ceo of the chronic cova
treatment center
you really have
you know a
start to finish approach to
making these long haul patients better
dr bruce patterson is a former medical
director of diagnostic virology at
stanford university school of medicine
he's now the current ceo of nceldx and
the chronic cova treatment center we
have over 24 000
long-haul patients
in our program that program is a
telemedicine and web-based care where
patients around the globe have signed up
at
covidlonghaulers.com to determine what's
causing their symptoms now there's a
whole spectrum of chronic inflammatory
diseases that share long-haul coveted
symptoms while the majority are being
treated for long-haul covid the unique
blood test has determined others have
something else like post-lyme disease
fibromyalgia and or chronic fatigue we
know from the patterns
in our test
whether or not and that's in the newest
publication of ours
we know the patterns
of lyme and we know the patterns of true
long cove and we know the patterns of
chronic fatigue syndrome so we can
appropriately classify them and
recommend treatments that are
appropriate for what they have and while
the company may have developed the tests
they aren't run by the company they're
run by
registered licensed
reference laboratories around the united
states
licensed laboratories in in the eu
and
and then what we do is use our
informatics
and ai to determine what they'll respond
to a recommendation then sent to your
primary care physician who then writes
you a prescription
if you think you might be suffering with
long-haul covet and want to sign up for
the program and get the blood test we do
have a link to the website for you on
our website at 8newsnow.com